[Music]
you know with all the talk about
single-digit numbers possibly being
available
max receivers tight ends defensive backs
linebackers
single digits so cool and all but can we
bring the throwback jerseys and helmets
back
somebody put in a request for that oh
well wait a minute wait a minute
you got a problem with the single digits
yeah guy who wore number two
yeah well i'm a quarterback i'm allowed
to wear number two okay yeah i got a
problem with single digits i do
you know the nfl has been working fine
with the number system i don't need to
find like
when i'm looking for guys now to have a
number five defensive tackle
and all that type of stuff it's not
gonna be a defensive tackle why
linebackers defensive backs receivers
running backs tight ends that's it it'll
be just them still
i don't like it just keep it the way it
is it's been it's been plenty good and
we got enough guys and like
you know weird numbers as it is we got a
lot of wide receivers and teen numbers
and things like that
it does we don't need to have single
digits we don't need it
all right all right old timer all right
old timer uh
so the you like the helmets though
yes but nobody really still understands
the idea why
one helmet and one helmet only is
conducive to health and safety
but that was the nfl's rule that was put
in place in three four years after
the hilarious that caused the nfl to
take head injuries seriously i mean
college they got a different helmet
hilarious as long as it's as long as
it's the right
style and make and it's survived all the
vigorous safety testing why
why can't you have a different one of
the exact same helmet
if they believe in the models of helmet
that they believe are so safe it really
is kind of a weird rule
it may go away this year nfl told me
over the weekend
it still hasn't been decided yet as of
last year the nfl's position was it
could go away as of this year so if it
does
throw back helmets that need to return
trivia question for chris the original
buccaneers creamsicle uniforms were
orange and white there was a third
proposed color
that was dropped in favor of red trim
how well do you know the team that
drafted you chris
what was the original third color for
the buccaneers
creamsicle uniforms with the base of
orange and white
wow i really don't know this but
since they're close to the university of
florida i'm going to go with like a blue
close good idea yeah green oh
green huh that was deemed to be
too close to the greenish hue of the
dolphins uniform the whole idea was
right
right the florida pastel
right right and it's
it's the nostalgia for the uniforms that
the team wore
in its horrendous two decades of
existence
it's amazing to me because they were
never any good in those uniforms but
people love those uniforms now
yeah i i mean they do i don't think i
want to see them
all the time it is one of those things
where it's just good every now and then
i think if you had to see it like
17 weeks a year you'd be like you know
what i've had enough of those things
they're ugly but like once a year twice
a year
i'm cool with that and that's the way it
should be and like listen
the nfl with this rule and the helmet
thing like get the hell out of here with
this crap
i mean are you kidding me are you
kidding me we
we can find a way to get an extra
playoff game we can add another week to
the regular season
but oh that extra helmet we can't quite
figure out how to do
that one oh okay that one we can't
figure out for player safety but adding
that extra playoff game in that regular
regular season game
the hell would that part bash that same
helmet one more time
makes no sense come on nfl like get with
the times let's go
if college can do it you can do it let's
go let me let me say this though before
we get into the pics
i hope that if they change the rule it
stops it too
because there will be an nfl equivalent
of oregon that has a different helmet
every damn week once nike starts
whispering in the area just do it just
do it just do it
let's have a different home and every
week you're going to be the most awesome
team in the world
i hope not i hope not that's the last
thing i when you turn on a game
and you don't know who your team is
because they've never worn that uniform
before and will never wear it again
right
that's what i and they're in single
digits then it's a disaster don't
i don't care about the single digits all
right uh for me
i i we it's it's it's it's bucko bruce
it is
it's i love seeing those and i wouldn't
want to see them all the time
but it's such a great contrast to what
the buccaneers currently wear i think
that's what makes it even better
it is so dramatically different than the
pewter helmets and the flags and the red
and the dark colors
that once a year twice a year you trot
out the pastels the orange and the
yellow and the white and the
and the pirate on the side and he's got
a sword in his mouth and he's winking at
you
to borrow a line from uh former pft
afternoon show co-host eric cacillius
bucco bruce put him back on the helmet a
couple of times a year
yeah i i hear that i think that that
would definitely have been in the
running for my top pick too i mean it's
a pretty
unique crazy helmet altogether so i i
get that
you know my first one mike i i gotta go
back to i'm gonna go to new york and the
giants because i'm
yeah i'm biased that way i've said this
many times
i like the old giant's helmet i like it
better than the one they got right now
but certainly if i could see a throwback
i know they put that sticker on there
you know once a year and do that
but it's that color to me that's special
right there
that real navy blue whatever i don't
even know if that's the
official color uh but that is what i
love
and that to me would be if you could
second helmet man the giants and that
right there
uh those are the good old days i i want
to see that one once again
that's really a stretch we've got blue
that's a little too shiny i want
blue that's a little more dull you could
have saved that one for round two i want
to take it now
i don't care i'm taking him right now
and it's a devil a different blue
one's like this is a dark blue the other
blue
is like a real true blue it's a
different it is a different hue
altogether
so go shove it go ahead pick your next
one thank you thank you
uh pat patriot speaking of contrast from
the alternate uniform to the current
uniform
i i i don't know why they got away from
the i i
like there was nothing wrong with the
original patriot uniform
and i remember when they got the new
helmet with the flying elvis slash
jay leno on the side the uniforms under
them were just
hideous so i i'd be fine with this being
the patriots ho
they are great permanent uniform yeah
and and yes
maximum number of alternate jerseys and
helmets per year whatever it is three
right now i believe maybe to go to four
and out those 17 games
but but bring those back those are great
yeah
they are i like that uniform all
together i mean i think the biggest
reason they change is just because it
was
you know associated with losing more
than anything don't you i mean it just
they couldn't get over the hump in those
uniforms so i went to a super bowl in
them they did
i know they went to one they got their
butts whooped 46 to 10. i could tell you
that much uh but
yeah i do like those that's on my list i
think my next one will be
um the dallas cowboys with that
white helmet they like to wear remember
back like early in the 2000s
they used to wear it on thanksgiving the
white helmet
was just the navy blue star and i think
there was one blue stripe that went
right down the middle
i think that's a classic you know going
back to their early days there i just
think it's got such a clean look and
then they wear that
you know white white jersey with the
blue patches on the shoulders and
everything that goes with it
uh to me that's one of my favorite
uniforms i've seen in football over the
last 20 years
yeah that was her original helmet the
white helmet with the blue star i
i'm getting my first three picks in this
draft i love this
because the eagles kelly green helmet
with the
the larger full wings the the silver
wings uh
vince papali the silver ring what did i
say orange should i say orange no i
don't think you say white silver wings
all right but anyway
i'm thinking of the the uh invincible
movie yeah um
the vince papali movie the ron jaworski
helmet definitely
i love those i don't know about i don't
know that i would go with the rest
i don't like that i don't like the
jersey or the pants
but the helmet make the helmet the base
of the rest of the uniform
update the rest of it start with that
helmet though that helmet's so much
better than the one that they have uh
great i i love that helmet
it's it's it's really one of my
favorites and yeah i mean it
to me really speaks eagles because i
think of jaworski
and reggie white and those football
teams randall cunningham
that's what they were wearing i actually
like that whole uni there but man those
those helmets you're right are special
that should have been my last pick i was
i don't know why i was saving that for
the third round and i shouldn't have
that was stupid of me
um so what did you say for the third
round uh to me it's it's i'm like torn
between the broncos
you know and their orange crush with
that blue or the falcons going to their
red helmets
uh but i think i'm gonna go with the the
the broncos the broncos helmet
you know the john elway broncos helmet
that's how i always think about them
right there there they are bam
i mean that that to me just when i think
of the broncos i still
think of that look right there and i
think that's john elway at the rose bowl
in super bowl
no that's not that's not super bowl 21
that's some other super bowl
but either way that's uh that that's a
cool looking helmet i really do like
that i'd like to see them break that out
once a year
is that young gary kubiak next to dan
rubio
no doubt about it i know i can't tell
who that is with the sunglasses though
that's driving me crazy i don't know
that i i don't know
yeah yeah yeah anyway uh other choices i
had the
oilers derek henry yeah would like to
have the
now with the oilers helmet is it the
white
or is it that blue i know do you prefer
i know i think i'd like the white i do
think the white the blue is cool
there is there is something to that but
i think the white is
is one that kind of pops more to me
i thought about the red bills one too
the red bills one from their
i didn't like too much too much the the
build
it was too big it just was it was too
busy yeah i
i like the white base helmet they can go
back to the and they still do that from
time to time the the buffalo that's just
standing still
back in the old days before they felt
compelled to make the buffalo run like
that's gonna make the players
seem faster because the bill on the side
of the helmet is actually running
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports